why shouldn't all students have a chance
at what you said was so important in
your own life look I grew up in a
working class family this was well
before any of this um of Public
Assistance for private school existed
and my parents made that choice I begged
them to send me to public school and we
sacrificed a lot there were times in my
family that we were on food stamps what
I want is for every public every student
in the state of Arizona no matter where
they live to have access to high quality
public education but if their system is
failing if their public school is
failing no to giving them a chance to go
somewhere else like you did the the
schools are failing because we are
failing to invest in them I actually
feel bad for Carrie Lee so they did
everything they could while they were
eating their little TV dinners uh and
they sent her to private school but she
does not want to give that opportunity
to other people